the 12th doctor I said that he could use
those eyebrows token bottle caps but can
you rob a bank window time ice now this
is a sort of a episode for dark dude
that can really go either way it's a
sort of very self-contained story it's
very confined to the single location
narrow corridors really big just kind of
reusing the same sets different lighting
different angles over and over again you
can catch what they're up to but that
doesn't necessarily make it a bad thing
when they do this sort of thing right we
get the god complex when they do it
wrong we get 42 time hikes lands about
the middle it's a decent opening setter
but actually I'll definitely grant this
season so far it's gone for strong
opening setups and the one where I
didn't like the opening set up which was
robot of Sherwood they did they sold it
once you were there so well didn't
matter
what we've got at the start here is the
doctor Clara and two new folks who we've
never met before getting instructions on
how to rob a bank and they don't know
what they're after or why they even
agreed to do it oh and they're about to
be discovered and incinerated on top of
that so we are literally off and running
right off the bat the new characters who
get thrown at us in this episode are
very lively the two people working with
Clara and the doctor to try and break
into the bank they got really strong
chemistry just the four of them together
they make a good team the villains in
this one you know sort of very proper
all business types works very well when
you're doing this sort of corporate
villain which this basically is we've
got our monster known as the teller now
this thing has been seen a fair bit in
promotional material we got glimpses of
it in various trailers there were photos
of it we didn't really know what it was
well it's a little frightening to be
honest and it works well for what they
intended for now as I said the episode
is fun it's energetic this series so far
seems to be kind of alternating back and
forth between light and bouncy and
heavier episodes we start off with one
that balanced that pretty well onto
itself and then we got a darker episode
then a lighter episode then a dark
forever so this one goes a bit lighter
again I mean the things called time
heist
it's a caper and if you have a caper
that's not fun well then it just fails
this is fun it takes itself perhaps just
a touch too seriously
and there's also a couple things going
on here there's a couple of
I hesitate to even call them twists but
there's a couple of revelations and sort
of additional pieces of information that
come in late in the game and about half
of them I get one of them I guessed
really early on another one I guess then
about five minutes before the reveal
happened and thankfully that doesn't
ruin the story because as I said I I
don't want to call them twists because
the story doesn't hinge on these ideas
but on my ye-yeah that that was a little
obvious that said there are a few
surprises that actually worked that play
well enough so I get it's a bit of a
balance Clara really seems to have found
her groove by this episode she's become
a bit more adaptable and just sort of
bouncing along with whatever the doctor
throws at her which is nice especially
considering where she started with the
episode deep breath which was compiled
these first episode where she just
didn't just wasn't rolling with this new
thing which I really annoyed the heck
out of me to be honest but now she seems
to have found her rhythm Aggie as a
character and the actress Jenna Coleman
has developed a pretty good rapport with
Capaldi as well now he is just he's
doing fantastic working the doctor feels
a little bit more of a focus on this
episode then he's been sometimes I was
starting to worry that he was gonna be
almost a little bit too much like the
first doctor where the Companions were
kind of pulling a lot of the the
action-adventure way and he was
basically just there to come up with a
clever idea with how they win this
episode he feels a little bit more
front-and-center than he has in some of
the recent episodes and that's nice
that's sort of comforting for me to see
that there honestly use it all that much
more to talk about this episode it's
it's kind of a filler one we don't even
get like the usual stinger we've gotten
at the end of episodes you know dropping
hints about the promised land with Missy
or whatever is going on we don't even
really get that so this this is kind of
a filler episode you get that feel off
of it it's certainly not a waste of time
but it doesn't quite have that more
raucous energy that robot of Sherwood
did and overall you just get the feeling
that it's kind of inconsequential it
reminds us of a few things that are
obviously probably gonna get touched on
and resolved but it itself doesn't add a
lot overall and while it's fun it's not
quite at the level that some of the
recent episodes have been so it is a
slight step back I hesitate to call it
or disappoint me because it's not I
enjoy the heck out of it but when you
set the bar you know this
and you have an episode that comes in
around here you kind of go home
didn't quite clue that bar still good
this got me it's not down here so this
is still good but you know so let me ask
you in terms of these sort of confined
spaces out running am a monster type
episode which one was your favorite I
mentioned a couple already including my
own favorite god complex but I would
consider things like tooth and claw the
Lazarus experiment even Dalek kind of
fits this mold so what sort of this type
of Doctor Who episode is your favorite
whatever it is drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it until
next time this council is adjourned